bonsoir et bienvenue dans kiosque
l'émission culturel au sommaire ce soir
le 21e festival de bandes dessinées de
Buc ce sont cette année une quentaine
d'auteurs invités et deux d'entre eux
sont sur le plateau de kiosque ce soir
coup de projecteur sur l'exposition
consacrée à Gérard Manoni au musée de la
ville à Montini le Bretonneux un
sculpteur qui a des liens particuliers
avec l'agglomération vous verrez ça dans
quelques instants la chronique de
Nicolas Gervet sera consacré à fixi il
sera en concert avec Winston MacAnuf à
la patrie de guillancour et puis la
chronique cé avec les avis des
spectateurs et le coup de cœur d'un
profofessionnel ce soir Cyril Hadad de
l'espace Philippe Moiret des clés
sousbois m place tout de suite à la
bande
dessinée le 21e festival de la bande
dessinée de Buc ce sera samedi et
dimanche au château de Buc le lieu
d'ailleurs d'une des aventures de Black
et Mortimer ça c'est pour l'anecdote il
y a 50 auteurs qui sont invités et parmi
eux Christian Gou bonsoir et Émilio
vaner Sweden bonsoir merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation et puis
également en plateau avec nous Juliette
espinose bonsoir mare ado déléguée à la
culture al on va commencer par vous
Christian Gou euh bonsoir vous avez euh
beaucoup travailler pour Pif Gadget
magazine de de Tintin aussi et puis là
vous venez au festival de Buc avec un BD
d'histoire sur la Grande Guerre oui vous
avez cette idée bon c'est c'est un peu
le centenaire en ce moment la Grande
Guerre raconter aux enfants raconter aux
enfants oui mais c'est la grande guerre
quand même alors d'ù vous ê venu l'idée
ben écoutez j'ai pas mal travaillé dans
l'histoire en bandessinée pour les
éditions phaton j'ai fait l'histoire de
l'art en
biné ensuite j'ai fait la vie de
Saint-Louis aux éditionsou à poiss dans
les poiss voilà j'ai d'ailleurs dessiné
pour les 800 ans de sa naissance à poiss
et ensuite donc on m'a proposé de faire
la bande dessinée la guerre de 141
raconter aux enfants alors je essayer de
donner une vision qui soit à la fois
alors on VO on voit la couverture not
band dessiné qui sera présenté en
avant-première on peut dire ça au
festival de Buc oui c'est ça est-ce
qu'elle vous plaît la couverture ce so
vous l'avez pas vu encore en coloris oui
je la découvre en même temps que vous vu
qu'on a eu des délais de fabrication qui
était extrêmement serré et j'avais pas
vu le la couverture et j'ai pas vu les
dernières pages en couleur non plus
ouais voilà la couverture regardez
vousy je reconnais le trait et j'admire
la couleur c'est bien ouais bah les les
poilus en en bleu hein
bien en bleu alors comment on travaille
quand on veut raconter la grande guerre
qui est quand même on peut dire une
boucherie c'était pas une période facile
oui c'est difficile c'est difficile à
raconter aux enfants alors il vaut mieux
quand même suggérer plutôt que montrer
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un bon
scénariste Guy le2 qui a pris qui s'est
un peu calé sur une narration pour
enfants don on a essayé d'être très
clair et graphiquement j'ai essayé de
pour avoir des points de repère pour les
enfants de faire évoluer toutes les les
forces alliées de gauche à droite et les
forces de l'Axe austroongrois allemand
et turc de droite à gauche c'est un
petit repère pour les enfants alors là
on a vu des extraits de vos planches de
B qui étaient en noir et blancétaient
pas encore disponible à la colorisation
parce que c'est vraiment pour le
festival de Bu qu'on pourra découvrir
l'album en couleur c'est vraiment une
une avant une avant-première donc vous
avez travaillé avec un scénariste on a
bien compris vous avez dû aussi faire
beaucoup de recherches je présume pour
savoir comment on dessinait euh
précisément ne serait-ce que les
uniformes des militaires oui et surtout
les les armes je dois avouer que je ne
suis pas très porté sur le l'artillerie
lourde ou légère et bon euh je me suis
un peu forcé à lire des ouvrages
documentés là-dessus et euh c'est pas
facile parce que suivant les années euh
l'artillerie évolué et disons il ne se
battaent pas ces pauvres gens en 1914 de
la même manière avaient les mêmes armes
qu'en 1918
on a montré quelques extraits des
planches on attend surtout de les voir
en couleur un petit mot encore sur le
quitter la grande Guare sur le lien que
vous avez avec avec bu oui ben j'ai tris
liens parce on entend bien de votre
accent que vous n'êtes pas natif de la
région parisienne et oui je viens du sud
de la Loire du midi mais j'habite
j'habite la région parisienne depuis
1972 donc j'ai perdu une grande partie
de mon
accent et Buc je connais Buc pour trois
raisons différentes la première vous
vous en avez un peu parlé c'est le cadre
de l'aventure de Black et Mortimer la
deuxième c'est parce que depuis 30 ans
j'ai de très bonnes attaches avec
l'équipe du depuis 20 ans pardon depuis
21 ans avec le festival de Buc puisque
je faisais partie de la première équipe
de dessinateurs invité et là voilà j'ai
même
je jolie médaille qui m'a été offerte
donc Christian Gou en habitué du
festival de donc on pourra découvrir
samedi et dimanche avons pr et la
troisème et dernière raison c'est parce
que c'est une belle région et en tant
que cyclot touriste je me suis beaucoup
promené à vélo avec mes amis tout à fait
donc vous serez donc présent je l' dis
au festival de samedi et dimanche pour
présenter la grande guerre raconé aux
enfants voilà àoné de vous Émilion V
derstuden bonsoir alors vous vous venez
au festival de Buc avec un album solo
McQueen oui tout à fait un polar je
dévoile pas pas plus vous allez nous
nous en dire un peu plus sur ce polar
oui
vraiment une nouveauté qui sort qui sort
aujourd'hui donc elle est à peine arrivé
en librairie qu'on qu'on se retrouve
déjà au festival ce weekend voilà alors
parlez-nous un petit peu de ce ce
détective un peu à la à la Philippe
Marlot hein tout à fait c'est vraiment
un un poard dans la ligée des des des
romans hardil des années 30 40
américains là c'est euh on dire un
hommage mais il y a pas que ça dans cet
album mais euh c'est un peu le principe
toute cette littérature du Poulp c'est
ce qui venait avant le le Pol proprement
dit céit le roman noir avec ces détectif
desabusés qui dangulaient dans ces
villes un peu sombres et et cetera donc
voilà je m'attache à à reprendre ces
personnages donc détective un peu
désabusé là celui-là McQueen il est plus
que désabusé il vraiment assez néé
d'ailleurs et euh et ces femmes fatales
ces euh ces rues lugubres et cetera quoi
et et ces enquêtes très allomiquées et
très tortueuses donc c'est aussi une
avant-première he festival de Bu qui il
est pas encore sor c'est la première
fois que je je le présente en festival
étant donné la date de sortie et c'est
vrai que ça me fait d'autant plus
plaisir puisque je suis assez attaché à
au festival de Buc c'est la trè fois que
que j'y participe et j'aime beaucoup ce
festival parce que c'est un pour moi
c'est un festival qui est un peu à
l'échelle à l'échelle du dessinateur on
peut vraiment rencontrer le lecteur avec
du temps contrairement à d'autres
festivals peut-être plus prestigieux
mais beaucoup plus grand et donc vous
êtes attaché au festival de Buc donc
vous présentez McQueen donc voilà pour
découvrir ce détective un
peu un peu trouble he
ouié unu un peu douteus pour arriver à
ses
fin mais il a quand même B il a bon fond
très bien donc j'ai dit mais chargé de
la la culture au-delà de la rencontre
avec ses auteurs c'est le festival c'est
aussi l'occasion de faire travailler les
jeunes autour de la BD il y a notamment
tout un projet avec un un collège de
saint-cier l'école voilà absolument donc
effectivement cette 21e édition est dans
la continuité des édition précédente
mais ça fait effectivement plusieurs
années que l'on développe des
partenariats avec les écoles donc par
exemple l'année dernière eroc nous avait
aidé il avait aidé plusieurs écoles de
du territoire de Versailles Grand Parc à
créer cette bande dessinée qui est
absolument magnifique et cette année
effectivement c'est le collège Jean
Racine de saint-tiire l'école le livre
allez le collège Jean Racine de
saint-tiire l'école qui euh vient
exposer des planches qui ont été faites
donc toujours avec un un auteur aussi
connu et reconnu et ces planches sont
sur le thème de de l'immigration et
elles seront présentées en exposition
pendant le festival il y a même un
concours pour voilà de pour savoir
quelle est la plus belle planche et voil
et voilà voilà donc ça c'est
effectivement la la bande dessinée qui
avait été créée l'année dernière par
plusieurs écoles de Versailles Grand
Parc et qui avait été effectivement donc
l'acent est mis effectivement sur les
partenariats entre l'éducation et la
culture c'est un sujet qui nous tient
beaucoup à cœur et donc on on vous
attend vraiment très très nombreux au
festival ce weekend et en plus les gens
peuvent venir voter absolument beaucoup
d'expositions en plus des animations
pour les enfants par nos animateurs de
centre de loisirs du maquillage du
dessin enfin plein de plein de belles
choses à réaliser ben merci à vous trois
d'être venu sur le plateau du casque
donc je rappelle le festival de la BD de
Buc au château de Buc qui a toute une
histoire avec Black et Mortimer donc
c'est samedi et dimanche de 10h à 18h
j'ai pas dit c'est gratuit l'entrée grat
c'est gratuit donc c'est vraiment
l'occasion si vous voulez rencontrer des
auteurs en cher et en de BD B il faut
venir au festival de Buc merci beaucoup
à vous trois on va continuer ce kiosque
on va maintenant parler de
poésie les nouvelles éditions de poésie
Veline un festival dédié à la poésie
créée en 2004 15 manifestations vont se
dérouler dans le département du 26
septembre au 5 octobre l'occasion de
rencontrer des poètes dans des endroits
très différents ça peut être des églises
des médiathèques ou plus classiquement
des librairies je vous propose d'écouter
Jacques Fournier c'est le directeur de
la Maison de la poésie qui a conccté le
programme il détaille notamment les
événements sur 50 ans nibline montrer
que la poésie existe qu'elle est vivante
là en ce début de 21e siècle et que on
peut voilà on peut découvrir la poésie
sous toutes ses formes grâce à ce
festival la première chose c'est le le
position qu' all là à la Maison de la
Poésie c'est-à-dire donner à voir les
les les les œuvres photographiques et
peintes de trois trois artist qu'on
avait mis en résidence de création dans
des lieux pendant poésyeline donc
Christian lotet photographe Adrienne art
photographe etbergeré peintre et poète
donc on montre ce travail à la maison de
la poésie pendant tout le mois de
septembre octobre le deuxième temps fort
sur saint-quenttin en Yveline c'est à
l'occasion du lancement de saison qui
aura lieu samedi 27 septembre à 19h30 la
remise du Prix poésie Eveline à Paul de
on donc ça c'est un étant fort pour nous
aussi et enfin sur saquentin en Eveline
c'est la rencontre avec Roland nado et
le comédien Charles Gonzalez chacun
venant présenter son dernier livre
Ronado sur le bouage et Charles gonzalis
sur le théâtre ça aura lieu à la
librairie Le Pavé dans la Mar et
l'ancour le
mardi 30 septembre à
19h30
et tout de suite la chronique de Nicolas
Gervet cette semaine Nicolas est allé à
la rencontre de fixi il sera en concert
avec Wiston ma Anou ce sera le 3 octobre
à la batterie DEUG en
cour accordéoniste voyageur amoureux des
musiques métissé il a uni son talent à
celui d'un artiste jamaïcain qui
collabore depuis quelques années avec
des artistes français voici donc fixi et
wilston macanf dans le kiosque s seront
le 3 octobre à la batterie à
gucour
bonjour aujourd'hui en fait on revient
d'une tournée brésilienne et Winston de
passer par la France il estarti chez lui
Jamaïque il a fait pas mal d'albums ici
notamment avec bas bas mais sous son nom
aussi il a joué avec beaucoup des grands
duget avec les
Congos c'est par l'intermédiire One donc
chanteur de Java avec qui bah donc qui
était mon collègue allit à l'époque il
ma dit au passage ce serait bien que tu
rencontres
Wiston sans doute un truc à faire entre
vous premier albumé l'album c'est sous
le nom de Winston prier disque dans
lequel partip des membres de Java plus
des invités des amis av déjà y avait
déjà
C on s retrouvé il y a 2 ans
pouravailler sur un nouveau projet qui
est
alum
c'est
aussi une rencontre musicale un peu une
rencontre humaine
d'énergie
d'alchimie je pense quelque chose
d'assez magique aussi avec l'accordéon
parce que s'est trouvé que le père de
Winston avait fait de l'accordéon enfin
Winston avait des souvenirs de son père
Jean l'accordéon tout petit il en avait
pas vraiment revu depuis donc il y a eu
quelque chose assez assez fort par
rapport à ça que il y a eu quelque chose
qui nous a qui s'est accroché entre
nous
souvent ce qui s'est passé c'est que moi
je lui apportéis des musiques et lui il
avait des mélodie
euh qu'il avait parfois même enregistré
avec d'autres d'autres morceaux qu'il
appliquait sur mes mes musiques et dans
le premier album il a aussi des morceaux
que lui il avait dans dans son sac donc
après que moi j'ai reprise et que j'ai
radapté à ma sauce avec mes mes
arrangements mes instruments et mais une
manière un peu basique c'est je lu amène
la musique et puis il chante par-dessus
avec ses textes et ses mélodies pour ce
deuxième album souvent on me disait bon
un moment il avait le truc et il fallait
que je branche le micro pour qu'il fasse
sa voix et souvent c'était la bonne la
bonne voix et ça se faisait d'un seul
coup comme ça quand on se retrouva avec
Winston chez moi tranquillement et
souvent je faisais écouter ce que
j'avais fait la veille ou l'avant-veille
comme idée et comme je te disais il se
mettait il se mettait à écouter dans une
pièce à côté et puis quand il était prêt
t il venait et on
enregistrait
il y a un passage avec l'afhrobit parce
que j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec Tony
Allen depuis une quinzaine d'années donc
c'est important de mettre cette ce
rythme cette cette puissance surtout que
wilston du coup par mon intermédiaire a
rencontré Tony Allen et il a été super
sensible et les Jamaïcains en général
sont super sensibles à cette à ce genre
musical donc on a fait deux morceaux je
j'ai composé deux morceaux d'aphrobite
avec Tony Allen il y a une partie maloya
aussi qui qui me vient de la Réunion
parce que j'ai beaucoup collaboré là-bas
avec un group s'appelle l'indigo
quelques morceaux regga il y
a des morceaux c'est très classiques
plus pian voie
et il y a des morceaux avec de
l'accordéon qui sontt plus tournés vers
Paris il y a des morceaux brésiliens
aussi avec espèce de de base de sambas
dedans
que TR sur scène ça différent du son du
disque assez composite il y a plein
d'invités donc Marcus à la beatbox
Winston qui est au champ et puis moi qui
qui transite entre l'accordéon et
l'album s'appelle nudet qui est le titre
dans des des morceaux et qui je pense
qu' a quelque chose d'assez qui
représente un peu
et notre nouvelle aventure mais aussi
l'aventure de wilston qui a eu des des
des père dans sa famille ce nouveau
travail artistique qui est aussi pour
lui et pour moi mais pour lui une
nouvelle nouvelle approche parce que
moins rég que les précédents et plus
d'espace pour lui pour sa voir pour sa
personnalité
comme pour moi aussi où j'ai plus plus
m'exprimer dans dans mes dans mes dans
mes goûts dans mes amours
musicaux voici pour Instone ma et fixi
le 3 octobre donc à la batterie à en
cour et maintenant on retrouve Catherine
en plateau et moi je vous dis à la
semaine
prochaine georgein chanter en blouse
c'est la performance des mon mon ils
seront en concert ce vendredi soir au
scarabé de la verrière pour ce spectacle
les prix sont compris entre 5 et 8 € je
vous propose un extrait les copains
d'abord non ce n'était pas le Radeau de
la Méduse ces bateau qu'on se le dis
fond des ports fond des
ports il navigu tempère pénard sur la
Grand m des canards et s'app les copains
d'abord les copains
d'abord c'est fluctu nec mergiture
c'était pas la littérature non desplais
au jeteur de sort au jeteur de
sort son capitaine et ses matelot
n'étent pas les enfants de salon mais
les amis Franco de P des
copainord voilà et brassin ça inspire
beaucoup les réalisateur en régie allez
un autre moment musical ça se passe à
l'abaye de Port Royal des champs à manie
les àot de l'émotion à l'Étap pure la
violencialiste Sonia Viader aderton joue
le répertoire d'une des plus grandes
divas du jazz du 20e siècle Nina Simon
un tout autre style amourpa cette fois
après une année de formation pédagogique
et de diffusion de huit groupes
ivelinois le réseau du cri propose un
concert de clôture de la sélection EV
life 2013-2014 c'est au café de la plage
donc à morpa à partir de 15h30 jusqu'à
20h et voici tout de suite un extrait
d'un des groupes présents sur scène
anakoï
room C deux constellation grand et
petite
ours je navais pas le souvenir de cette
casserole de taille moyenne entre les
deux
c'est l'événement culturel du début de
l'automne 24 pour 24 pour 24 an de
spectacles de Danes et de concerts le
vélodrome de 50 ansine s'est associé
avec l'association Juste Debout t va
regrouper des artistes internationaux le
27 septembre à partir de 14h et notez
que TVF vous proposera de revivre
l'événement avec une édition spéciale
kosque mercredi
prochain
oh allez une date pour les plus jeunes
Isabelle Gourdet de la compagnie les
trois ailes compte et chante aussi
accompagné d'une guitare elle remet au
goût du jour des chants traditionnels et
des contines un peu oublié c'est samedi
matin à les staminé de Manil àau et en
plus c'est gratuit tout de suite le
cinéma allez on va terminer kiosque
comme tous les mercredis avec la
rubrique cinéma vos avis de spectateur
éclairé au micro d'éodim moine c'est
très flippant c'est très bien mais je
trouve que ça a été présenté comme une
comédie alors que c'est c'est un peu
drôle mais pas tant que ça quoi c'est un
super moi je trouve que c'est plus un
vrai polar que qu'une coméie dit voilà
c'est très bien joué c'est parfait c'est
une très belle intrigue et j'ai adoré
d'un bout à l'autre c'est un super
scénario bien
construit il y a de l'intrigue jusqu'au
bout ça finit un petit peu bizarrement
mais super j'ai bien aimé j'ai trouvé
que sa vie était très difficile et mais
par contre il avait un génie il faut
voir les collections qu'il faisait mais
il a une vie très difficile c'est c'est
pas mal il y a quelques périodes de
flottement c'est très bien réalisé euh
parce que j'ai bien aimé il y a pas mal
de flashback qui qui entrecoupe en fait
l'intrigue principale c'est c'est c'est
très bien fait j'étais ravie de pouvoir
découvrir la vie de jam parce que je
suis fan à la base et ou super histoire
très émouvant moi qui pleure facilement
j'ai mon lot de de larme très belle
histoire et je suis encore plus fan donc
je crois que je vais remettre le CD dans
la voiture dès tout à l'heure
voilà beaucoup d'émotions chez les
spectateurs allez comme tous les
mercredis un professionnel du setiamar
nous donne son coup de cœur ce soir
Cyril Hadad de l'espace Philippe Noiret
des clés sousbis cette semaine le coup
de cœur de l'espace Philippe Noiret est
le film nos étoiles contraires film
américain réalisé par Josh boun depuis
son enfance Azel a des problèmes
respiratoires l'obligeant à porter un
tube à oxygène en permanence sur les
conseil de sa mère elle participe à un
groupe de soutien où elle va faire la
connaissance d'Augustus qui a perdu une
jambe à cause d'un cancer le jeune homme
devient rapidement proche d'azel lui
montrant le beau côté des choses leur
amitié se transforme peu à peu en amour
jusqu'au jour où la maladie revient les
hanté entre rire et larme ce film est
une véritable ode à la vie où l'humour
des deux jeunes personnages l'emporte
rapidement sur les bons sentiments ce
mélodrame bien ficelé touche en plein
cœur le spectateur l'interprétation des
acteurs principaux est vraiment
excellente nos étoiles contraires est à
découvrir cette semaine à l'espace
Philippe no si tu savais à quel point je
te suis reconnaissante pour notre petite
infinité la vie est belle à Zelle Grace
ok
ok et puis on finit avec l'exposition à
découvrir en ce moment c'est du côté du
musée de la ville de Montini le
Bretonneux Gérard Manoni expose donc au
musée de la ville ce n'est pas un
inconnu dans l'agglomération l'artiste a
participé à un projet collectif autour
de la gare la place de la gare c'était
dans les années 70 il il a aussi réalisé
dans les années 90 une sculpture pour la
ville de guilloncour et là il revient en
invité d'honneur pour expliquer son
travail sérieux comme il dit un sujet
complet que vous pouvez retrouver sur le
site internet de TVfil 78 allez cette
émission est maintenant terminée merci
de votre attention toutes les infos
pratiques les dates de l'actualité
culturelle de 50 ans nieline c'est bien
sûr à retrouver sur le site internet du
kiosk bonne soirée à la semaine
prochaine d'ici là gardez l'esprit
ouvert et
curieux